so i just published my first first
starter review article with my group
leader musashi so hello and welcome to
the cheeky science show where in this
video i will highlight the key points
for my article be wrote together because
why not there are a few covers p53 and
cellular senescence so if either of
those topics is of interest to you or
you're just intrigued to hear what
researchers do and how we go writing
about these things then watch on
so firstly as i said this is a review
article not a research paper so we
summarize and discuss well as much as
possible
research articles relevant to my two
topics i spend much much time thinking
about cellulose in essence and the
world's coolest protein p53 so firstly
an introduction to each
p53 this is a protein that is expressed
in your cells the canonical function of
this protein is to enter the nucleus of
the cell where it acts as a
transcription factor it regulates the
expression of genes by binding near the
gene and bringing in cell machinery that
causes transcription
this is the first step of gene
expression where the dna sequence is
read and an rna copy is made
this rna copy is then read to make
protein
usually levels of p53 protein are kept
quite low within a cell
only when a cell becomes stressed does
p53 protein accumulate
it can then enter the nucleus and
regulate the expression of other genes
one of the most famous targets of p53 is
the gene encoding the protein p21
p21 is a protein that can stop a cell
from replicating
this is thought to be beneficial under
stress as it gives the cell time to try
and resolve the stress if the stress
isn't resolved then the cell may
transition into cellulosin essence
which was a nice segue to tell you about
cellular senescence
and so when a cell enters senescence it
not only stops dividing but it also
develops a secretory phenotype referred
to as the senescence-associated
secretory phenotype or the sasp as we
like to say
this refers to soluble factors that are
secreted from senescent cells that
include a smuggler's board of components
these components influence the
surrounding tissue environment and
enable communication between cells for
example components including
inflammatory factors that can activate
immune cells
for example it includes components like
inflammatory factors that are thought to
be able to recruit and activate immune
cells that could underline clear
dissonance cells
now as you can see in this beautiful
figure that i made earlier we showed
that p53 influences both the cell cycle
arrest and the sasp
i've already established how p53
promotes cell cyclist but the sasp now
that's more complex
there are two main transcription factors
nf kappa b and cebp beta that control
many sasp components
however it seems that p53 can influence
these factors such as indirectly
regulating nf kappa b
some earlier work showed that if you
knock down p53 as in reduce the overall
abundance of it in a cell then certain
inflammatory factors
seem to increase suggesting that p53 has
a repressive component over the sasp
and so it's important for me to
highlight what i've written here which
is a simplified view of how p53 governs
the cell cycle arrest and the sasp
although a few firstly isn't complete
but the second thing we were trying to
highlight with this figure is that the
two components the cell cycle arrest and
the sasp seem to be decoupled that is
you can repress one component without
affecting the other
however again i'm going to have to
emphasize the word simplified as this
recent paper describes how p21 can also
influence the sasp so if i had a hula
hoop representing each aspect the cell
cyclers and the sasp then there probably
would be some kind of overlap between
them but i think you should also try and
imagine as if both of the loops are
currently being hula hooping
and so they sort of oscillate in terms
of that overlap
in other words this is my way of saying
that we don't fully know how but what it
does reinforce is the idea that p53 must
be tightly regulated to control its
various activities and snattons
and the reason we think that p53 needs
to be tightly regulated is because p53
is a bit of a track of all traits well
not quite all trades but cellulosin
essence is just one of many things that
p53 appears to control
other aspects include causing cell death
so clearly something unique or a
collection of unique things is happening
to control p53 such that it results in
senescence and not one of these
alternative outcomes
and these unique things include
controlling how much of p53 is present
its localization whether it's in the
nucleus chilling in the cytoplasm
or up to lay good at the mitochondria as
well as p53 modifications such as
phosphorylation acetylation and
ubiquitination
these can influence the stability the
activity and the location of p53
and in terms of its activity i've
mentioned already it's a transcription
factor and it does this by binding to
dna
and earlier work for my lab before i
joined looked at where p53 binds in the
nucleus on dna
because p53 doesn't just bind anywhere
it binds near to genes it regulates the
expression of
p53 is known to bind to specific
consensus sequences
known as the p53 response elements
the word consensus is the perfect word
here but that's its own story of his own
what i want to say is that our lab
looked at where p53 was finding when
cells were happy and growing
when there was the initial acute stress
and when the cell had entered senescence
and the most interesting observation was
that p53 bound to its response elements
when there was acute stress and internet
sense
but in senescence and another form of
more chronic stress
you could also see these broader p53
binding sites
in so called cpg islands
and so again i tried to beautifully
depict this in my figure where we can
see where we think p53 binds in these
different scenarios
so this is sort of where the catchy
title comes back it's a marathon not a
sprint
which i have to be upfront and honest
and say that this title was not my idea
shout out to joanna and her genius brain
because senescence isn't a sprint at
least in cell culture experiments it can
take days to establish
and like how you would prepare
differently for a sprint versus a
marathon the regulation and downstream
consequences of p53 also appear to
differ
we refer to p53 here as chronic to
distinguish it from the canonical acute
response
we just don't have the complete picture
yet
but part of the reason we see
differential binding of p53 in chronic
kind of acute phases could be due to the
changes in the accessibility of dna
basically how the dna is compacted and
localized within the nucleus
our lab is interested in how dna is
packaged in the nucleus during
senescence and how this relates to what
genes are being expressed
a paper published from our lab
fortuitously a few days before the
review came out
showed that internet sentence we see the
expression of genes that we wouldn't
expect to be expressed
in senescence long cells we can see
aberrant gene expression of skin genes
in growing long cells these genes are
tightly packaged and repressed
but in senescence they're decompacted
but the decompacting alone isn't
sufficient and guess what two proteins
were identified to be involved in
enabling the expression of these skin
genes
one protein we briefly met earlier ceb
beta try saying that 10 times super fast
and the world's coolest protein
so this is the final section of the
review trying to understand the
consequences of p53's actions
this is a more recent emerging area of
interest in our lab but i can't help
draw comparisons to more general
theories of aging
namely sinclair's informational theory
of aging whereby as cells age they lose
their identity
so for example here how the lung
fibroblast cells are expressing skin
genes so losing their identity
so maybe part of senescence is a loss of
identity due to average regulation of
genes
but it's also possible that maybe these
skin genes do have a functioning
senescence we just don't really know
what it is yet
but still it's all pretty interesting
and so the best bit of all of this is
that my article was open access so any
of you can read it and get all those
extra nerdy details should you wish
and yeah as i said at the start this is
my first first author paper even if it's
just a review i still think is pretty
cool
i hope my phd work will be able to add
to our understanding and will share what
i have when i have it
so yeah that's it review articles are
really quite challenging to write but
very rewarding as it encourages you to
really think about data published and
where there are unanimous results or
conflicts
the big challenge for me is both
senescence and p53 are very big topics
and so trying to read everything is near
impossible but i do what i can
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening
you